even with a great director like Tim
Burton who's this legendary Larger than
Life character are there times on set
where a big director like Tim Burton or
you're watching something and it's just
in your thinking yep that's not what I
want how do I tell Tim Burton this
how do I say Tim yeah this is great but
it's it's not yeah we would go you're
Tim Burton we you know but we want to be
deeper we want to be respectful of your
process and we don't want to like so how
do we do this so how do we do this and
he was and we'll say that initially and
he was very he was very intrigued by the
idea of doing TV yes and he was very
intrigued telling his story over a
longer form so he had never really done
TV
never never he just didn't understand
how some things were going to cut
together right and then when we saw his
first cut we were like holy well
it's just the economy it's shots it says
the opposite of a TV director who just
covers the out of a scene Yeah Tim
shot with one camera
one camera